we live in a medication nation 4.5
billion drug prescriptions will be will
be prescribed by doctors like me this
year in the United States alone that's
15 for remand woman and child and for
most of us our experience with this
medications is often confusing number of
pills instructions side effects
one-size-fits-all dosing which all too
often we aren't taking as prescribed and
this comes at tremendous expense costing
us our time our money and our health and
in our now our exponential connected
data driven age I think we can and we
you must do better so let's take a dive
at some of the challenges we have and
some potential solutions let's start
with the fact that many drugs don't work
for those who are prescribed to them for
the top 10 grossing drugs in the United
States this year they only benefit one
in four to one in twenty three if you
take them that's great if you're number
one but what about everybody else and
what's worse drugs when they sometimes
don't work and still cause side effects
take aspirin about one in four of us who
take aspirin to reduce our risk of
cardiovascular disease are unknowingly
aspirin resistant and still have the
same risks of gastrointestinal bleeds
that kill thousands every year it's
adverse drug reactions like these that
are by some estimates the number four
leading cause of death in the United
States my own grandfather passed away
after a single dose of antibiotic caused
his kidneys to fail now adverse drug
reactions and side-effects are often
tied to challenges in dosing I trained
in pediatrics little-people internal
medicine big people so one night I might
have been on call and a NICU carefully
dosing to the fraction of a milligram a
medication for Nikki baby the Nets night
on colony emergency room
treating a 400-pound lineman or a frail
nursing home patient who while by most
accounts usually we get the same dose of
medications from the formulary which
would mean most the time I'd be under
dosing the linemen and overdosing the
nursing home patient and beyond age and
weight we tend to ignore differences in
sex and race in dosing now behind
this we know we have a massive challenge
with non-compliance or low adherence
many of us who need to take our
medications aren't taking them or are
taking them incorrectly you know 40
percent of adults in the US over 65 are
in five or more prescription medications
sometimes 15 or more and even small
improvements in adherence can
dramatically save dollars and lives so
as we think into the future you think
that we where we are today as we often
hear about smart personalized targeted
drugs Internet of Things gene therapy AI
that we'd already arrived in this era of
precision medicine in reality we still
live in an age of empiric trial and
error in precision medicine I think we
can do better what if we can reimagine
ways to help make your medicine taking
easier to get the right doses and
combinations to match you what if we
could move beyond today's literal
cutting edge of toe cutters and fax
machines to an era where we can have
better outcomes lower costs saving lives
and space in your medicine cabinet
well I think part of the solution is all
the emerging ways that we can measure
and connect our healthcare information
today we pretty much live in a reactive
sick care world siloed information that
doesn't flow we have the potential to
move into more continuous real-time
proactive world of true healthcare and
part of that starts with the emerging
world of quantify itself we can measure
so much of our physiology and behaviors
today and often as solid on our phones
and scales but is starting to connect to
our clinicians our caregivers so they
can better optimize prevention
diagnostics and therapy and when we can
do that we can do some interesting
things
take for example hypertension it's the
number one risk factor for early death
and mobility worldwide half of adult
Americans on approximation have
hypertension less than half have it well
controlled it's often because it takes
two or three different classes of
medications is tough to do adherence and
adjust your blood pressure medications
we have 500 preventable deaths from non
controlled hypertension in the US every
day but now we're in the era of
connected blood pressure cuffs the FDA
just approved a blood pressure cuff that
can go into your watch there are now
prototypes of cuff less radar based
blood pressure devices
can continuously stream your blood
pressure so in the future I could
instead of spot-checking my blood
pressure in the clinic my doctor could
see my real-time numbers and my trends
and adjust them as necessary with the
help of a blood pressure dosing
algorithm or our using the Internet of
Things now technology today can do even
more
my SmartWatch RT today as an EKG Bilton
that can be read by artificial
intelligence I'm wearing a small
band-aid size patch that is
live-streaming my vital signs right now
let's take a look they're actually a
little concerning at the moment yeah
uh-huh now it's not just my real-time
battles that could be seen by my medical
team or myself it could be my
retrospective data and again that be
used to modify dosing and medication
going forward even my weight can be
super quantified my weight now my shape
how much body mass fat muscle mass I
might have and use that to optimize my
prevention or therapy and it's not just
for the tech-savvy now MIT MIT engineers
have modified Wi-Fi so we can seamlessly
collect connect and collect our vital
signs from our connected rings and smart
mattresses we can start to share this
digital exhaust our digital and even
potentially crowd sources sharing our
health information just like we share
with our Google Maps and driving to
improve our not our driving but our
health experience globally so that's
great we can potentially now collect
this information what if your labs can
go from the central lab to your home to
your phone to even inside our bodies to
measure drug levels and other varieties
and of course we're in the age of
genomics I've been sequenced it's just
less than a thousand dollars today and I
can start to understand my
pharmacogenomics have my genes impact
with our need high dose low dose or
maybe even different medication
altogether let's imagine if your
physician or your pharmacist had this
information integrated into their
workflow augmented with artificial
intelligence AI or AI Elektra Ferda is
IA intelligence augmentation to leverage
that information to understand of the
18,000 or more approved drugs which
would be the right dose in combination
for you so great now maybe we can
optimize your drugs and your doses but
the problem today is we're still using
this amazing technology to keep track of
of our drugs and of course these
technologies of Valders connected
dispensers and reminder apps smart pill
bottle caps that can text or tweet you
or your mother if you haven't taken your
medications pill pack was just acquired
by Amazon so soon we may we may have
same-day delivery of our drugs delivered
by my drone so all these things are
possible today but we're still taking
multiple pills what if we can make it
simpler I think one of the solutions is
to make better use of the poly pill a
poly pill is the integration of multiple
medications into a single pill and we
have these today and comment
over-the-counter cold and flu remedies
and there been prevention poly pill
studies done giving combination of
statins blood pressure aspirin which in
randomized studies have been shown to
dramatically reduced risk compared to
placebo but these poly pills weren't
personalized they weren't optimized to
the individual what do we could optimize
your personalized poly pill so it would
be built for you based on you could
adapt to you even every single day well
well now in the era of 3d printing you
can print personalized braces hearing
aids orthopedic devices even I've been
scanned and had my jeans tailored to fit
to me so this got me thinking what if we
could 3d print your personalized poly
pill so instead of taking six
medications for example I could
integrate them into one so it'd be
easier to take improve adherence and
potentially could even integrate in
supplements like vitamin D or Co Q 10 so
with some help I call these Intel amends
and with the help of my intimate as an
engineering team we built the first in
telemedicine prototype printer and
here's how it works instead of full
tablets we have small micro mats one or
two milligrams each which are sorted and
selected based on the dose and
combination needed for any individual
and of course these would be doses and
combinations you could already take
together fda-approved drugs we could
change the pharmacokinetics by
officially layering on L of different
elements to the individual Micro meds
and when we hit print
you print your combination medications
that might be needed by you on any
individual day and we'd start with again
generic drugs for the most common
problems about 90% of prescribed drugs
today are low-cost generics and once
we've printed the pill we can do some
fun bells and whistles we could print
the name of the patient the date the day
of the
week a QR code we could print different
meds for tapering for patient on a
steroid taper or tapering from paying
medications so this is actually a look
at our prototype in telemedicine printer
see on the valent here
it has about 16 different silos each
containing individual micro meds and I
can now adjust on the software
individual dosing and when I do that the
robotic arm will adjust the height of
the span shalls' and micro medicine
release I can now the automated process
would rotate and cycle through to make
sure the micro meds are loaded and then
with when I hit print these would all
fall through them for the device I now
pull out my personalized printed poly
pill with the doses and medications
meant for me and we can sort of take a
look if you look back to the slides here
a minute so the whole process we can see
the drug silos being selected the pills
going down to different silos and being
collected in the individual capsule now
this is great I can potentially put my
meds based on me instead of taking six
pills I can now be looking at my
individual dosing my SmartWatch is
looking my blood pressure I need an
adjustment my blood pressure medicines
my coumadin level my how thin my blood
is too thin so I lower my micro med dose
of coumadin a blood thinner so this
could be smartly adapted day to day
program by my physician or cardiologist
and you can imagine that larger printers
fast printers like this could be in your
corner pharmacy in your doctor's office
in a rural clinic but it could
eventually merge and shrink to small
ones that could be in your home with
integrated cartridge like this that are
delivered by drone could print your
personalized poly pill each morning on
your kitchen or your bathroom cabinet
and this could evolve I think into an
incredible way to improve and adherence
and medications across the globe so I
hope we can reimagine the future
medicine in new ways moving from
polypharmacy one-size-fits-all low
adherence complications to an era of
personalized precise on-demand
medications that can take us and
individualize our own health and health
and medicine around the planet thank you
very much
Daniel that's kind of awesome really
cool question for you though how long is
it until say that nursing home patient
that you mentioned is able to print
their pills in their home well again
this is just a prototype we think that
the regulatory route be automated
compounding and especially in nursing
homes folks are taking multiple
medications and they're often mixed up
so it'll be a perfect place to start
with these technologies these aren't
going to evolve and start with printers
on your bathroom counter so I think we
need to be intelligent and smart about
how we roll these things out but
realizing that there's so many
challenges with dosing adherence and
precision and now that we have all these
amazing new technologies that can
integrate and be leveraged I think we
need approaches like this to really
catalyze and foster a true future of
health and medicine great thank you
Thanks
[Applause]